no they don't
they don't deserve it they are gonna
shame them yes i'm gonna [ __ ] shame
them
uh
they don't deserve it because i've made
what sixty seven dollars sixty seven
dollars oh that's enough hey three more
dollars guys
embarrassed
nice
um but it doesn't matter because you
know what it's not about money it's
about sending a message as the joker
would say
uh dayton hypernova let me read the
title of this one
um
today about transphobia last night sis
bro in law harassed me physically then
adorned two rainbow flags
my shirt came in too danny i'm just not
wearing it because i have the washer
because it smells like printer
ah
oh god i've never seen it in the
daylight uh-huh it's different it's a
different light this is friday morning
is the day after a
crazy
incident of my
older sister and my brother-in-law is he
really taller is that just a very low
ceiling no he's not tall he's not so
he's short actually it's a very large
people much larger he's finally in a
different room hold on can you give me a
second he's fat shaming his family older
sister and my brother-in-law her husband
they're very large people much larger
than me and stature and physically i
think it's probably because they eat
more than a than one [ __ ] uh
diet burrito health burrito excuse me
so is this black friday and the families
go on shopping yeah and he just has free
room in the house correct and then he
can make his little videos downstairs in
the summer yeah yeah all right
so how how long before he accuses his uh
black uh
brother-in-law he's going to call his
black brother-in-law an n-word very soon
it's coming get ready because he doesn't
have his brother anymore
this is like a view into the future
though when all of the parents have died
and he's the last one stuck in the house
and he'll outlive them all all of them
built like football players essentially
they're overweight
large people
both taller than me i'm like five and
eight there you go
no i guess my sister is five seven
so she's like an inch shorter than me
why does he have the smug face on i
don't get it either
what is he so smug about
a very tall woman
but like a football player
physically shoving me around in my room
with her husband both of them physically
shoving wait wait wait wait i had to get
out of the room five seven is tall
to him
hey taper i need another i'm gonna need
another uh thumbnail
all right
dayton hypernova's manic black friday
thank you that's the title thank you use
whatever picture you want of him pushing
past them in order to get a bottle of
water downstairs because my mouth was so
parched
stop talking yeah shut the [ __ ] up and
nobody told you not to come downstairs
and get a glass of water but you know
what if you don't want to be around
people drink out of the toilet
huh from the console so if all his
family members die and he's the only one
left you know he'll be complaining that
they're haunting him at night of course
they're haunting him he's already
complaining sherman's gonna haunt him
shout out and shouting back from getting
shouted at by these people and it
started with my mom shouting at me like
crazy about using the shower that they
just installed to wash my face the only
reason i turned it on to use it
was because anytime i use the
um the faucet on the sink in the
bathroom i get shouted at because i get
showered by her
same person
who shouted at me for using the
shower
to do it yeah
anyway truthy now like he's just like he
talks like this now he's just every time
and now it's time for everyone's
favorite
you in the segments to try to figure out
what drugs are they on something's gone
wrong what drugs are they on
[Music]
vibrance
oh good one vi okay that's not bad
i was gonna go with adhd medication but
also xanax
i'm gonna say coke because it goes like
this now possibly or you know or legal
speed it could be adderall a lot of
adderall
jar stuffed with
[ __ ] and roadkill that he huffs in a
corner once a day it's very specific i
don't know but i don't know enough about
him to not know if he's doing that
so uh
i seriously use the shower because i get
showered at for using the sink because
the sink gets stopped up by literally
anyone who uses the sink regardless and
they constantly know where that wouldn't
happen your own apartment
he accused me of it being
stopped up for that reason when it has
to do with them i haven't used that sink
now and
i don't know a year and a half at least
i stopped using it a long time ago
because i got shot on a daily basis oh
he's slurring a bit do you noticing that
too yeah he's shouting out
is drunk maybe
we know he likes his wine dayton likes
dayton likes her wine
for using it to wash my face and i guess
their argument was that my hair would
get into the
drain or something so i started using
this shower instead
because there's a larger drain in the
shower so what he's doing is he's not
using his shower right or his sink
he's using their new shower
because it's new because it's new
it's crazy because they went so crazy at
me last night how crazy were they
because i was getting shot at for a half
an hour that's a terrible joke
i set them up and jesus
and then obviously in the middle of
shouting at me i shot it back because
it's absurd by the way every time we've
seen a shouting thing you start the
shouting
i've never seen a video of you yelling
at them where you weren't the instigator
that kind of abusive remember when he
yelled at his dad because he got pizza
from the wrong place yes yes to a person
who was getting beat remember then he
got yelled at his mom because his mom
got mad that he he used her credit card
to buy dresses for his fake store
without telling her what happened to
that by the way oh that store never
worked because you know it was a
terrible business model where you don't
have to pay for clothes
well the store works it's just in his
attic and no one goes there but him and
the aluminum foil art
don't forget those things are also in
his attic
he spent seven years in this house by a
skin head
oh here we go that dude in that oh my
god are you [ __ ] serious mm-hmm
sherman has found his way
that's amazing sherman's dead and he's
posting a picture oh my god oh my god
it'll be really funny if you watch
his other videos and you notice that no
matter what room he goes in that phot
that pictures
he shouts at that picture
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you dayton
you [ __ ] ghoul
you are a [ __ ] ghoul man
what the [ __ ]
it's not a bad portrait it's not bad no
i agree
wrong kid dad
um
that picture was beating me
six foot tall skinhead x-boxer
he's um your brother's dead dude
overweight by the time he was living at
home beating me
so he was even bigger than he was when
he was boxing notice how he has all
these balls when no one's in the house
notice how ballsy he is yeah beating the
[ __ ] out of me for wearing dresses in
front of them no he beat the [ __ ] he
never beat the [ __ ] out of you because
of the dresses you beat the shitty
because you're insufferable
because you hit him also because you
started all the fights
yeah
and these people act in denial and they
go on this gaslighting routine about how
clearly i must be unstable and i still
haven't why would anybody think he's
unstable
that's because these videos
clearly show how much you're the same
person
stable dating is what i call them i've
gotten any explanation from them about
why i would be on
is that why we call them date and hyper
normal yeah it's state hybrid over yeah
yeah
yeah that's why they call them cade
pleasant doxa
unstable on any level just for getting
beat
that's crazy
stupid absurdity that it's mind-boggling
absurdity that seven years of violence
to me is excusable because they're
assuming because they weren't physically
they were not physically present during
most of the incidents but not all of
them because they were milking it apollo
creed already died you can't keep making
movies about him
find a new villain
does
the the sherman have a son out there
somewhere i don't know oh god i would
the dayton would be hunting him down
surprises during some of them uh and
that danger goes over they're dressed
like buffy the vampire slayer
they're just gonna have the benefit of
the doubt
why why would they have the benefit of
the doubt is it are they accusing his
psychosis to be hereditary in some way
for me it's not and i'm not crazy
because i got beat
no you got beat because you're crazy
i'm obviously very rational about how
wrong that is and how wrong it is to
ignore that he's very rational
now go get me my health burrito get me
my sunday skirt and give me a credit
card so i could buy more aluminum foil
for my art that no one's gonna see
i'm very rational of mine right now
remember when you started a fight at
outback steakhouse for no reason
by the way those are the eyes of a
rational person yeah look at those eyes
very rational
so despite my anger which could be the
only thing
someone could have possibly even vaguely
accused me of yeah
i would despite all my rage i'm still
just a trans in a cage
would be so
weirded out if i wasn't a like angry
about getting beat shut the [ __ ] up
the police laugh at you in that town
doesn't make sense
so i'm getting this on video only right
now because in this moment because it's
the next day and i look out the window
and something that i just he's such a
[ __ ]
that not only is he doing his video he's
doing it right by the front window so he
could see when they get home
notice a broad daylight they don't just
have one rainbow flag on their house on
the um
on the uh front porch over the uh
front door there they have one right
there
in the side window so you're mad that
they have pride flags
okay
why would that make him mad shouldn't he
be happy that they have pride flags
that's so nice they're hypocrites
because they allowed a so-called
skinhead to beat him for seven years in
his house in that house thank you well
the house that he's in two rainbow flags
in their houses these people have never
stood up for me through all of that but
you know who else hates you dayton
the entire lgbtq community in dayton
because they've said it
so even your own people don't like you
and now uh because i was shouting back
at my mom
about
her belligerence at me for using you're
not allowed to yell at your mother
because you are a 35 year old man living
in her home for free you lost that right
you don't get to yell at your elderly
mother or your retired father
or your dead brother
or your black brother-in-law
so i it was my turn to poop so i quietly
muted and i went and i decided oh i'm
gonna pop in i'm gonna check in on the
show so i i open it on the youtube app
and it plays an ad for anti-semitism
what
that's amazing the ad was an
anti-semitism psa before
really weird why would that be the ad
i don't know okay
the shower tool the shower faucet to
wash my face
uh
did you wash your face with a
sandblaster
you piece of [ __ ] let me make any sense
it's so mind-boggling that's frustrating
it's like uh i was getting shot out so
crazy that they uh my parents had them
come over and harass me and it got
physical towards me they were physically
pushing me when i was in my room trying
to walk away from the argument
oh here's the thing
i'm such a liar
yeah i don't believe this happened
because i feel like he films everything
and he would have rushed to throw that
up somewhere it would have been awesome
exactly dude
he would have filmed while it was
happening to go see look you're beating
me
up they said no we don't represent the
video evidence sir
me out
thank you out right there my
brother-in-law called me a lot of
four-letter words
okay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
if they tell him he's being a [ __ ] dick
you're being a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dick [ __ ] dick yeah homo
punk homo almost four-letter word
yeah
tr tran
no not training wouldn't work you know
gay
oh that's three nevermind
it could be four with the h she may have
gmail's too long yeah
hey honey what's a four letter word
twice words [ __ ] that's a good one twice
yeah
and [ __ ]
told me that i'm clearly unstable it's
like why am i unstable i'm getting
shouted at for no good reason by people
in the same house where i was getting
beat
why am i unstable
i mean
what do people think i'm crazy why do
they think i'm crazy everyone thinks i'm
crazy i'm totally normal
this is the 21st century you can't just
throw the word unstable at someone who's
getting beat for wearing dresses you
cannot wait
stable
fairy unstable is a bad word now
everything that you talk he's a
perpetual victim
throw
belligerent accusations out of people
while you're being belligerent at that
person who's getting beat i mean they
are clearly unstable to begin with if
they're coming at a person physically
pushing them in their room keeping them
from going downstairs to get water
because the shouting that was going on
for uh 45 minutes at that point i think
drink out of the toilet like the animal
you are
or something it was an absurd amount of
time
a completely stable person would totally
make erratic videos like this right yes
this is what normal stable people do
frozen hmm i've not subscribed
you're doing it wrong
write in your notebook be crazy yell at
family this is going to help you
wait how does that get me with women
because they'll know you're you're that
you're the alpha male of your family
okay
think about it it's pretty obvious
and also okay frozen make sure you wish
everyone a merry munchkin
everyone a merry christmas
got it okay and also ask the girl over
she'd like to come back for a cuppa
senka
would you like to come over for a cup of
sangha also would you like to meet my
gas can yes the gas can't thing i
wouldn't say but everything else is good
my mouth was completely dry make sure
you harden
leave the gas can out of it uh there's
no gas frozen
frozen it's important that you hear that
i say you have to get rid of that gas
can
i have psoriasis all over my face which
is one reason why i had to wash my face
it's ridiculous because i'm in physical
pain on my face from the beginning i'm
in physical pain from listening to you
complaining about your face hey does
your face hurt no it's killing me
i don't it's not bloody right hey dayton
does your face hurt yes
oh
oh okay
oh no obviously but it's uh
erythrodermic psoriasis covers my body
uh and it bleeds from stress factors
like getting beat in the house by a skin
head he said
the line
he said
the line
oh old reliable dayton
in front of these people
it's crazy someone in the chat called
him flaky pastry leaky pastry that's
what he is
filo dough looking [ __ ] [ __ ]
pastalito
you you buckle up a skinned [ __ ]
hey hey croissant face
[ __ ] it seriously
oh
how much butter was folded into your
[ __ ] skin look at that flake
a strudel mug
and anyway i'm getting this on video
only for now because for this moment now
seeing because i looking out the window
and seeing that freaking the at on their
house they have two freaking rainbow
flags there that's obnoxious to have
rainbow flags and decide on a neutral
point of view about violence to a trans
woman in that house that you bring your
children to be babysitting you're not a
woman
all right we get it over we get it
turnover skin you [ __ ] apple turnover
skin that's good yeah
in front of a skin head
yeah
yeah i'm a little bit angry i think
you're a [ __ ] you're only angry when
they're not home you [ __ ] aphrodite hey
cannoli puss
stop cannoli plus come on and that's not
unstable to be angry by itself kevin
mcallister when he finds out he's home
alone like i'm gonna i'm going through
my dad's things no one better stop me
incoherently
belligerent to be uh someone who's
considered unstable and that's exactly
the quality that describes my sister and
her husband my brother-in-law who were
going crazy at me so badly that they
were shoving me in my room pushing me
and cussing me listen here trans crouton
nobody [ __ ] cares about you
or all the things that make you sad
you're pariah you're the [ __ ] worst
you're the [ __ ] worst you said you
were going to be out of that home and
you were leaving 50 times your dad even
offered to give you seven hundred
dollars if you said if you promised that
you were gonna leave and not come back
you didn't take it cause you're [ __ ]
and you can't be alone and when you
moved in with your friends they threw
all your stuff in the yard because you
were insufferable to live with
me out very
okay that's not nice do you think he'd
live well in a group home or something
like that no because then he had to be
around other people
no they beat him too yeah they beat me
in this group home no evidence of that
now and uh audio too that's crazy okay
can i see it the audio and instead of
this can i see the audio though and
stuff with that that'd be cool
obnoxious dayton get your cheetos off my
off my bed dayton
so royce let me ask you a question sure
so you again not giving anything away
but you said you do know family members
how hard
would it be to get a camera in that that
upstairs area
to catch him to catch him not only or at
least train the family to film his
[ __ ]
right
can you imagine can you imagine a video
from mom's point of view and i've tried
this right
and the problem is is that i understand
their side of it they're like i don't
want to be in these videos to begin with
and the last thing i want to do is
embarrass myself
by posting videos of this [ __ ]
why should i give them to us
no i get it i get it i mean
i don't know i mean is it possible sure
it's possible
i mean
i think that would be awesome i feel
like some yeah
i mean you couldn't do it you could tell
them that it's just like you know
it if you if they do that then at least
they can catch the fact that he's
instigating all this [ __ ] and maybe get
him out of there
that's a good point i don't know i could
try let's see you know i'm going to see
what i could do
it's like because i was setting up an
interview with sherman before he died
and i didn't even get that done
two weeks later and dayton's banned from
argentina yeah uh by saying in the chat
what are we the nsa now
what no no no no i wasn't saying put one
in there illegally someone would know it
was there no no no no his dad is his
dad's house right or his sister or
whatever yeah
yeah they're saying when they're saying
when dayton comes at them filming they
should pull out their own camera and
film him from their point of view that
way he can make all these lies up
horrible people this is like the this
was like last night this was the last
uh uh what am i saying that was that was
the freaking most obnoxious experience
i've had of belligerence within my
family since uh the skinhead was uh
living here like a year his name is
sherman yeah he's already dead sir
ago he passed away
january of uh this year
uh ever since he passed away it was a
pretty quiet year until i got that kind
of crazy interaction with two very large
people who are way larger than me both
hold up hold on hold on hold on
it was a quiet year yes because they
were mourning your brother's death
you gangly
heroin addict looking [ __ ] that is
i hope he haunts you just because i
forgot hilo back
just because your [ __ ] skin is made
out of parmesan doesn't mean that we
have to [ __ ] deal with any of this do
you hear me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
your skin is the air from the upside
down in stranger things
sorry sorry
sorry that your face is made out of sun
chips like what do you want from me
right in front of mom and dad
who didn't do anything about that they
didn't stand up for me and that one why
would anybody stand up for you dayton
and listen i mean this
if i were to see you getting murdered
and all i had to do was go hey stop it
and the guy wouldn't kill you he
wouldn't do it no i would just let it
happen i would just let it happen
hey dayton if kids in the nearby high
school throw up does the janitor shake
you over the vomit to make it easier to
clean he's not made of sawdust
either which is crazy
that none of these people are of a sound
mind about you're right they're nuts
violence mama my mom even freaking said
down here
after all of it no when she was uh no
proof didn't film it no proof
because she realized that she was
obviously overboard about things and she
didn't apologize to me at any point
during the uh point of her uh quieting
down but she would talk to my sister
down here and i overheard her uh saying
well boys will be boys when it comes to
wrestling and violent like any kind of
wrestling behaviors like that was not
wrestling first of all it's not if it's
not consensual to get
thrown to the ground what
apparently his brother raped him
consensual wrestling
what is consensual wrestling
smacked hit punch in the oh it's the
next nxt pay-per-view name ribs oh wait
wait i got it i got it says the next
match that they're going to give joe
gacy got yes in the face smacking the
head all of that [ __ ] by a much larger
human being that's not wrestling that is
physical assault and it happened a half
a dozen times a span of seven years
that's absurd
anyway i'm done it's ridiculous
ah and that's the end of the video
sir yeah can you please sweep the stairs
no no no he's too busy screaming about
getting i'll give you five dollars
to sweep the stairs uh honestly i'll
tell you that cause he's always worried
about money i mean
dayton please let we'll help you get
into live streaming
yeah go let me have to pause on the
stairs because to show how dirty he is
yeah that's him
that's his skin
yeah it definitely is you're seeing the
only thing he's useful for is when it
snows he can salt a driveway that's
about it